welcome to the mckayla peterson podcast
in this episode i interviewed
nina teisholtz author of the
international bestseller the big fat
surprise
investigative science journalist and
tedx presenter
i've read her book the big fat surprise
and i've lent it to my friend so i don't
have it here to show you
but if you need info on fat and how it
got demonized
and what to eat i really do recommend
checking it out it's linked in show
notes
we took a deep look into the stigmas and
actual realities of eating fat
we covered topics including why we're
told fat is bad for us
saturated fats vegetable oil substitutes
how fat got demonized in the first place
hello conspiracy theorists effects of
high and low ldl cholesterol
the monetary incentive to use fat
substitutes and more
nina's a journalist who did a very good
job of unearthing the facts behind fat
consumption
forgive the video quality in areas we
did as well as we could but there are
areas that are a bit glitchy
if you have relatives or friends that
are worried about cholesterol and fat
consumption
this is the podcast for them this
episode is brought to you by truelocal
trulocal.ca is where i get my meat
you choose what goes in your box and
they send it to you flash frozen
it's super high quality they connect
with local farmers and then you get to
buy
farmed meat sustainable nutritious
delicious
i recommend they're grain-fed beef wild
salmon and their lamb is
bomb code mp for free stakes in your box
mark the ceo has been one of my biggest
supporters
and was sending me me when i was having
a hard time affording it too
a couple years ago so that's very nice
trulocal.ca codemp for free stakes with
your box
please remember to check out my clip's
channel in the pinned comment on youtube
or at mckayla peterson clips on youtube
and rate and subscribe enjoy the episode
next episode is an opposing views
episode on
[Music]
abortion
[Music]
nina taishals welcome to my podcast
thanks for having me it's good to be
here
i don't think we've covered this before
on my podcast to deep
dive into fat and whether or not it's
bad
i have a list of questions but one of
them is the because it sounds
for people who don't know it sounds like
a conspiracy theory i know
and that's always you know fun but the
uh you know nutritionist being paid off
or dietitians or pharmaceutical
involvement so how did the demonization
of fat
even start like why were people told
that fat makes you fat okay
i'll go back to the beginning story but
first i just want to say that
um this idea that it's a conspiracy
theory
i mean in any field of endeavor
um a journalist is taught to is to talk
to follow the money
right but in nutrition somehow we think
nobody follows the money the reporters
on nutrition come out of the health fee
you know they come out of sort of health
and wellness and they're not really
following the money and if you start to
follow the money you see a very
different picture
um but anyway in my case
my my interest in trans fats translated
into a book that
took almost 10 years to um to research
and i interviewed hundreds of scientists
and the the origin story
of how we came to demonize fats really
starts in the 1950s
when the the whole nation is in a panic
about the rising tide of heart disease
heart disease had been almost
non-existent in the early 1900s and had
risen to become
the number one killer in the nation so
just imagine you know
your father drops dead of a heart attack
but you know
it's never nobody's ever seen that
before and then finally
there was a kind of focusing moment in
1955 when president
dwight eisenhower had a heart attack and
was out of the oval office
um for 10 days so trump was out of the
office for
a few days at the hospital and it was
just constantly on the news but you can
imagine 10 days
eisenhower's in the hospital and the
entire nation is focused on
this issue what caused what causes heart
disease what causes a heart attack
um and there were a number of theories
at the time that were that were
proffered by respected scientists one
was that it might be vitamin deficiency
another pers another scientist argued
that it could be the rising tide of auto
exhaust that
people were breathing in other people
thought that it was a type a personality
that you go around
yelling at people all the time and then
suddenly you drop dead
um but the theory that one was
um suggested by um
the um physiologist ansel keyes who was
a professor at the university of
minnesota um i have written about him in
my book others have
have written about him as well he was a
his idea
was that it was saturated fat and
cholesterol
that would uh raise the cholesterol in
your blood
you would eat saturated fat and
cholesterol it would raise the
cholesterol in your blood
that would sort of clog your arteries uh
like hot oil going down a cold
stove pipe and that would give you an
a heart attack so this was called the
diet heart hypothesis
and that was um that was just sort of
the commonly used
term and that for you know for decades
everybody
went by the diet hypothesis
in any case ansel keyes was um a very
interesting individual he had a kind of
unshaken faith in his own belief
i interviewed people who said it was
impossible to argue with ansel keys he
would
argue anyone to the death even his
allies and friends
thought him to be a very aggressive
personality
and he was able to get into the american
heart association which was the leading
group counseling people on heart disease
such that in 1961 the american heart
association which is under a lot of
pressure to tell the public we have an
answer to heart disease
um again something that we can connect
with now with it
seeking an answer to covid the american
heart association in 1961 comes out with
the first ever advice
anywhere in the world telling people to
cut back on saturated fat and
cholesterol in order to
avoid a heart attack that is
as i've often said the tiny little acorn
of advice that grew into this giant oak
tree
uh that we have today telling people
that saturated fat and cholesterol have
to be
reduced cut back in order to prevent
heart disease
so um i mean the story from there
is super interesting because the
american heart association at the time
like had no rigorous evidence for making
this recommendation
they had something called a seven
country study which shows association
but not
causation um so there were no
clinical trials really showing that this
is true
and then the next two decades the 60s
and the 70s
you see this unfolding of
of governments all over the world
undertaking
large randomized controlled clinical
trials which is the gold standard of of
science and they they test like
over 70 000 people on this idea
you know they test them on on the idea
that saturated fat and cholesterol cause
heart disease this means they divide
people up into
two groups one group gets the hamburgers
the regular cheese the regular milk the
other group gets soy filled cheese soy
filled milk and some version of
today's impossible burger and they
tested these people in trials that
lasted
up to 12 years and in none of those
trials
did they find that the group on the soy
filled everything that group did not
die they did not live longer they did
not
uh the the cardiovascular mortality the
total mortality which means death from
any cause
all of that was the same in both groups
but
you don't hear about yeah so this
science was i mean the story that
um that i was able to uncover and also
um the journalists gary tabs i mean we
really dug into these studies to find
out that many of them were
misrepresented by the authors themselves
so they said they found things that they
didn't
they were misinterpreted at the time um
one of the studies the minnesota
coronary survey which was the largest
ever study in the u.s
that included both men and and and women
which women were generally not included
in trials
that study didn't go published for 17
years
they didn't publish the data this was a
trial funded by the national institutes
of health
and when a journalist much later asked
one of the lead
uh investigators well why didn't you
publish the study um he said well
there was nothing wrong with the study
we were just so disappointed in the way
it came out
wow yeah that's not how you're supposed
to conduct a scientific experiment
that's not good science there's actually
a little code to that story
which is that much later investigators
at the national institutes of health
were able to go back and find the
original
computer files from that study that were
in
the the basement of um the one of the
project leaders
and they ran a lot they analyzed those
tapes and they discovered that
data that had still not been published
which was that the more the men were
able and women were able to lower their
cholesterol
the higher the likelihood of having a
heart attack
wow so so i mean so this is all to say
that
ancil keys had a hypothesis it was
tested
it was tested probably more than any
other nutrition hypothesis has been
tested
and the results were as if they say in
science null they could not
they could not provide they could not
find evidence to support ansel keys
hypothesis
and there i would say there are people
who say look those were not good trials
this was wrong that was wrong
this was not controlled this was not
good enough and and
and you know which i i understand some
of their criticisms and i would probably
agree with some of them
but even then your fallback position is
well
then we haven't tested his hypothesis it
remains a hypothesis
and like any hypothesis it is just an
idea it should not be imposed
as a policy on the entire population of
the world
if you don't have good data to support
it so it was a hypothesis with
really good marketing it was and i guess
the idea the idea
you eat a whole bunch of fat and it
clogs your arteries it's a
it's a pretty good like elevator pitch
idea
it's easy right for people to be like
okay that makes sense
you know let's say it caught on i mean i
think that there
were obviously some commercial forces at
work
um like the american heart association
happened to be a recipient of
a great deal of funding from procter and
gamble
which coincidentally made um
crisco oil and um
procter gamble has always has long been
a
tremendous support of the american heart
association so the american heart
association had a major conflict of
interest
when it came out saying you know eat
these vegetable oils over saturated fats
i think that in the 60s and 70s i think
that
there you can at least my impression
from my research is that
scientists genuine many scientists
genuinely also believe this idea so that
it became this kind of dominant
hypothesis
and it became almost like an orthodoxy
like a belief and
there were many scientists who truly
ardently believed in this idea
and then so then any critics and there
were of course plenty of critics along
the way
who came out and said we don't have
enough evidence what about the contrary
evidence what about this what about that
which is evidence i kind of review in my
book and i show but
what happened to these critics was they
were really um
again the same sort of story as like
being yelled at when you're presenting
your paper at a conference they were
just sort of
silenced they were drummed out of the
field they could not get research grants
they
i mean science is a little bit of a club
and if you're not going with the
dominant idea i mean
one would hope it would be otherwise but
in fact the critics were
um didn't they they suffered in their
careers and were diminished
uh by because they had spoken out
and that of course sends a message to
young scientists in the field coming up
which is don't go there and i spoke to
plenty of those scientists
who said you know i don't dare publish
that i can't i can't report on those
results
um because i won't advance in the field
um
and i think ultimately that's why
journalists have you know it's fallen to
journalists to
to bring out the science that has other
would otherwise
have been lost and forgotten that's
interesting as i was going to say like
why isn't it
why isn't a scientist outing this stuff
but
perhaps because what like you said
journalists are the people who
try and follow the money or figure out
these problems it does actually make
sense that the journalists would have to
figure this out and they're not risking
right
their scientific career exactly yeah
exactly i mean i don't have to go to a
water cooler and chat with
you know that somebody who is a faithful
adherent to ansel keys's theories
so journalists are independent um and
that's what gives us
uh it just gives us a little more
freedom what is a saturated fat
and a polyunsaturated fat very good
question all right we're going to diet
we're going to do a little bit of
chemistry
so um saturated fats
all fats first of all all foods except
for sugar
have a combination of all types of fat
so
you know even vegetables have a tiny bit
of saturated fat in them
but saturated means um
that the molecules that make up fats
which are mostly a chains of
carbon surrounded by hydrogens that
in when they're saturated they're
saturated with hydrogen
it means that they are there's no double
bonds in them they can't take any more
any more additional hydrogens and
because of that they're flat they are in
a straight line molecules and they lay
on top of each other one leg after this
and that makes them densely packed
together the molecules and that makes
them hard
they are solid fats butter butter ghee
lard tallow
duck fat i mean they're all hard fats
and they do not have
any double bonds and they're straight
molecules polyunsaturated fats
have poly multiple double bonds the
double bonds
make little crits in the chain and so
the molecule is kind of a wiggly
molecule full of double bonds
that means they can't pack together
tightly and therefore
there's space between them and that
means they're oils sunflower safflower
canola oil
soybean oil all of those are
polyunsaturated vegetable oils
and the key thing to understand about
why
they're uh not as safe or you know we're
told to eat um
all of our fats really is unsaturated
polyunsaturated fats
those double bonds when they're exposed
to
light or air over time and especially
when heated
heat is what speeds up all chemical
reactions those double bonds
open up and they attach to
oxygens oxygen is that means
you know what we know as oxidation right
and the reason that we take
antioxidants so peop some people take
antioxidants is to try to get rid of
oxidation oxidation is not good for your
body because it causes
inflammation and inflammation is
experienced by people
in a number of ways sometimes it's just
that you you know you get arthritis or
your bones hurt or you have you know
inflammatory issues inside your body
and it is thought to be a major cause of
heart disease as well that's why when
they test your
crp is and there are other inflammatory
markers that are
reflect the inflammation in your body
polyunsaturated fats
are a major source of that inflammation
from your diet
other sources of polyunsaturated fat
nuts tend to be quite high in
polyunsaturated fats and chicken
is higher than red meat chicken and
turkey tend to have more polyunsaturated
than saturated fats
although i just want to go back and say
again like a a piece of steak
has some polyunsaturated fats in it
because all foods have
some combination and if you will indulge
me just one more second i will tell you
about olive oil which is unique
and coconut oil because they get hard
right when they're cold
coconut oil happens to be although it's
called an oil
it is it is very high in saturated fats
it's something like
80 or 90 saturated fats i forget that
means
so it is almost entirely saturated fats
um
same with palm oil which is used in a
lot of manufactured foods and processed
foods
but there is one type of oil that is a
monounsaturated fat
mono one double bond only does not cause
so much oxidation
does not cause um so much inflammation
and i'll let you guess what that is
yeah olive oil olive oil right so olive
oil which is known as oleic acid
is is a has only one double bond and so
what manufacturers of vegetable oils try
to do is they try to
mix oleic acid or olive oil with their
with their highly polyunsaturated fats
in order to make them more stable
these these vegetable oils are highly
unstable
and um and we should all be afraid of
them in the sense that they're used in
almost
all restaurant cooking you know all the
french fries at mcdonald's everywhere
you go
um there these are the fats that are
used in cooking
and they pass through you know they they
enter the food
in which they're being fried they pass
through the blood brain barrier
there they they degrade as they're
heated over
time and degrade into hundreds of
of various kinds of degraded
triglycerides and other
other molecules um including known
toxins one of which is called aldehyde
and is a known toxin that causes cancer
so this is like this
is not this is information that is not
widely known
and um was completely shocking to me
when i stumbled across
it what was the book that you wrote the
big fat surprise
the big fat surprise yeah it was um
it came out in canada too published by
simon schuster and
really the central argument of the book
is that
um is that saturated fats which have
been more vilified than other fats for
decades
that these fats and meat and butter and
cheese
are do not in the end they're not bad
for you they don't cause heart disease
as
long has been thought and is the
original reason that
people started decreasing the amount of
red meat that they ate because
red meat tends to have more saturated
fat in it
how did you start the book and when did
it come out and what was the response
and why why did you write it
well i'm a journalist and i didn't know
much about nutrition um and but in the
early 2000s i was doing a series of
investigative food stories um for
gourmet magazine which is a
which is what was no longer is a high
level food magazine in the united states
and one of those stories that i was
assigned was on the subject of trans
fats
well i had never heard of trans fats um
this was before they became well known
and that story really caused me to take
a deep dive into the world of fat
fat in general you know good fat bad fat
non-fat
all kinds of fats because in researching
for that story
as i started to interview scientists uh
i heard these just unbelievable stories
about
how some woman researching trans fats
had
um had the the margarine
sorry sorry people from the margarine
industry
had come and tried to get a academic
journal to yank her paper
or how um people also from the margarine
industry hired
scientists to stand up and yell at her
at meetings to try to
bully her out of the field another
scientist i talked to had successfully
been bullied
out of the field after 25 years of
research just saying it was so
impossible to
um to do anything in this area because
we were harassed at meetings and it was
so hard to get our work published and we
couldn't get any money for it
and i i came to understand that there
was
i mean it seems obvious to me now or
or maybe obvious now but there's just
this huge
food industry and it turns out also
pharmaceutical interests
um that are behind a lot of food science
and so
so scientists who are trying to do
honest work and may discover something
that is
um you know not favorable favorable to
the food indus
industry they they really are bullied um
and there's it's very hard to do honest
research in this field and it turned i
just thought
the nutrition world seemed a little bit
more like the wild west than what i had
imagined um as being a kind of
it's not what i learned about science
you know science was supposed to
unfold in in a rational way with honest
earnest discussion
can you give us a brief description of
what exactly cholesterol is and how
that could be affected by how much
whether or not it's affected by how much
fat you eat or what type of fat
so just start with what cholesterol is
briefly
cholesterol is a very complex
complicated molecule
uh in your body and i i don't know if i
i'm not going into the chemistry on it
like super simple
it's in every cell of your body and it's
used
to create um any number of
a wide array of things including your
hormones including your sex hormones in
uh including um it's used for
in in your skin it's used i mean your
cholesterol is this
essential molecule in your body and if
you aren't eating it your body knows how
to produce its own
um which is why reducing cholesterol in
your diet like avoiding shellfish and
avoiding egg yolks was
you know always a kind of nonsensical
idea because
even if you reduce eating it your body
will make it or your body will try to
make it as much as possible if you're
eating
zero cholesterol people tend to struggle
from having depletion of cholesterol
but you know in the beginning there was
just total cholesterol
that is what ansel keyes and his
colleagues in the 1950s were studying
which is your total cholesterol they
were
really convinced that it was cholesterol
that caused heart disease
um and that had to do with the fact that
there was this
there was a phenomenon where people get
these fatty deposits on their skin
that when they open them up it's filled
with cholesterol
it's like it's um i forget what it's
called a kind of disease
that's concerning and i don't i don't
know what caused it but then
and they so so and they they did these
so they assumed that what they were
seeing here
was also the way the cholesterol would
would coagulate in your arteries that
was just an assumption
that that would be the same and they did
experiments on
animals to see if this was true and it
did turn out to be true but they
experimented on herbivores
not on omnivore animals so like they
experimented on rabbits
say and that is not reflective of what a
human
a human's experience of cholesterol is
so
um so cholesterol then
they became more sophisticated and they
could they were able to measure
your what's called your good cholesterol
your hdl
and your so-called bad cholesterol your
ldl
i'm sure you're familiar with those
terms right yeah yeah you
want your you we were told okay you have
to
lower your ldl and raise your hdl
and it turned out that saturated fat
would raise your ldl
a little bit um and you know broadly
speaking
so then they started focusing on ldl
instead of total cholesterol
um it was discovered at some point in
the
70s or or early 80s it was discovered
that total cholesterol in the end did
not
really track very well with heart
attacks
in fact there's quite a lot of
literature to show that people who have
heart attacks
um they're just as likely to have high
cholesterol as low cholesterol
uh and so they started focusing on ldl
ldl was the culprit
and um but in the late 80s it was
discovered that
ldl did not really track very well with
heart attacks this is still science that
is
out there but it's um also science that
is ignored
um and that it turns out that your
hdl is a this is according to the
framingham study which is a
huge huge epidemiological study your hdl
your so-called good
cholesterol was a much better indicator
of your cardiovascular risk in other
words the risk of having a heart attack
well um what what causes hdl to go up
uh well when you go to because when you
go to your doctor and he says you have
low hdl probably not you
but i'm sure your listeners you go to
the doctor your doctor says you have low
hdl
um and i still have a little a little uh
medical form where this happened to me
when i was in my my early 20s and he
says you know
don't eat saturated fat and get more
exercise
doctors tend to tell you to get exercise
drink more red wine
the most effective way to raise your hdl
is to eat more saturated fat
that is the only food that reliably
increases
your hdl um
so i mean cholesterol is extremely
complicated because
of the involvement of the pharmaceutical
industry and i don't know how much you
want to go into that but
you know the biggest i definitely want
to go into that the the biggest
blockbuster drug of all time
are statins of course statins are
designed
to lower your ldl and the new generation
of
pks 9 inhibitors also targets ldl
so in the world of pharma
which is you know hugely uh i mean
they're just
they're a huge force in the world um
they they're completely focused on ldl
and
for them ldl must be bad and therefore
in order to be consistent saturated fat
must also be bad
because saturated fat tends to raise
your ldl
so the pharmaceutical industry tried to
find a drug
that could raise your hdl but they
failed
there were numerous drugs that ended up
with terrible side effects that ended up
uh actually killing people so
so they they've sort of they've decided
that hdl is something to be ignored
despite all this data showing that hdl
is actually
as a better predictor of cardiovascular
risk and they focused entirely on ldl
which is really an imperfect indicator
of your cardiovascular risk in fact
just as many people die from heart
attacks who have high dl
ldl as low ldl there really is almost
no there's no correlation at all so
um so we live in a world where all of
our understanding of these
cholesterol risk factors um
are you know are very much manipulated
by
the pharmaceutical industry um and i
don't want to say you know
even ldl itself is complicated i don't
want to say it plays no role but ldl
has sub-fractions and different sized
particles
and so it's i mean we could get into
that if you'd like but
it is very very complicated and i think
maybe the one of the overarching stories
here is that
all these ideas about what was good for
health and what was a good diet to eat
were made
in the absolute infancy of understanding
heart disease and its causes
it was just sort of a leap to a
conclusion
about saturated fat and cholesterol
in the infancy of the field um and so
and you know it was it was a hypothesis
it was a guess and it just
it turns out that it was the wrong guess
and uh
and we have ever since been trying to or
some of us have been trying to
back out of that okay so
just to summarize um there doesn't seem
to be a clear link between
high cholesterol and having a heart
attack correct
okay but because of all this
i guess what you could call propaganda
um
beforehand we have a pharmaceutical
industry that's pushing
statins to lower cholesterol to avoid
heart attacks even though there doesn't
seem to be a link between cholesterol
and heart attacks
that would be roughly right okay yeah
that definitely doesn't sound
good i think that yeah i mean there
are nuances and subtles used in that but
that is is basically
we are um we've been encouraged to lower
our cholesterol and
and there's very little data to support
that there's quite a bit of data to the
contrary
and the remedy which is statins isn't
there data
that having higher cholesterol
is better particularly for women that's
a vague
yes yeah so can you get into that a
little bit
yes i there's a section in my book
called women and children which
made me so sad to write that um i still
can't go back and read it
but it's about how all the experiments
were on middle-aged men because of
course initially was only middle-aged
men who had heart attacks
and because scientists are middle-aged
men probably as well
um but there was really almost no data
on women
and then when they finally did study
women in that framingham
study notably they discovered that
women who were 50 or older
i believe it's 50 but it the higher
their cholesterol
the longer they lived yeah and this was
a contrary finding
and it was decided that to have separate
advice for men and women
was too complicated so they would just
tell women to do the same thing as men
which you know is in retrospect um and
really unforgivable but it's also true
that high cholesterol in men they would
they could only find a correlation
between that and heart attacks in a
very small band of men like 51 to 58
years old or something i mean for all
other ages and especially in the elderly
the higher your cholesterol was either
neutral or
beneficial for avoiding a heart attack
this is we're talking total cholesterol
now yeah but you know how many doctors
do you go to when you say and you have
high cholesterol and your doctor says
congratulations you must be doing
something right
yeah right it's interesting so i've been
eating
like fatty meat right so the amount of
saturated fat
i eat is way higher than what the
average person
eats i would assume because i eat fatty
meat all the time
and my cholesterol i haven't tested it
too recently but i did rob wolf's rob
wolff like
got me to do a bunch of really in-depth
testing and my cholesterol was still
like in the according to the test in the
super healthy zone
it hadn't budged i have no idea why so i
don't know if it's because i'm young or
because of who i am i also know low
cholesterol runs in my family
which isn't necessarily a good thing
uh but it hasn't what i've been eating
hasn't changed my cholesterol
cholesterol at all but i know some other
people who've gone on the diet
and their cholesterol has gone up so do
you do you have any information on
how much fat that was one of the
questions people asked is
how much fat is too much um particularly
with saturated fats
well um or is it just dependent on the
person
yeah i mean i i want to give one
specific and one vague
answer um the specific answer is that
in all those clinical trials i described
on more than 60 000 people
the amount of saturated fat that the
group
the control group ate which is
considered normal
for you know in the american diet was
about 18
of calories that was considered what was
normal in the american diet
okay so now we're told to eat 10 or less
um so it so 18
is what has been tested in clinical
trials
and found to be safe um i mean in
i multiple clinical probably eating 70
of my calories
at least from fat as fat but not from
necessarily saturated fats remember your
porter
your porterhouse steak is maybe
one-third saturated fat and otherwise
your
your um there's another third part of it
is polyunsaturated and part of it is
uh oleic acid like olive oil so so the
saturated fat that you're eating
is um you know it might be over 18
i don't know but i i will tell i'll give
you okay let me give you another
specific data point to
rely on which is a study that i'm sure
you're familiar with but
um i described in my book about uh two
men
one of them was um uh stefan steffensen
who
went to the arctic and lived with the
inuit and um ate
only meat and fat and um when he came
back to america and he wrote his book
about it everybody thought he was crazy
so he undertook an experiment with a
colleague of his um
in new york at a local hospital where
they they were they ate only meat and
fat
for an entire year in the beginning they
kept him in the hospital right to make
sure he wasn't cheating
yeah i think initially for the first few
months but then they were sort of
let out you know on their own and but
they were then
they were followed by a team of experts
and um
there were six papers that came out of
that where they measured everything that
could possibly be measured
and they found them to be in absolutely
perfect health
and in fact the one instance that he
describes where he was feeling poorly
was when he thought he had been eating
mean that meat that was overly lean
and was not fatty enough and he resolved
his
um discomfort by um frying up
fattier meat i think he said with brains
in order to
make himself feel better but there's a
long literature
also that i go through in the book about
how
how overly lean meat was considered
inedible because it did not have enough
fat in it it was just considered
you would you would have too much
protein without
fat is was regarded um i know this is a
subject of contention now but was
regarded as
unhealthy and i think one of the most
compelling examples of that that i found
was that you know the party of
um was the name of lewis and clark who
traveled across the country
and you know discovered the west they
described in their journals
and an event where they went out hunting
for meat
and they came back with all this um
deer and and other meat they had hunted
but they said they had to throw
it all away because it was overly lean
and could not be eaten
which is weird completely fascinating
and also repeated in the experience of
the inuit who would say they
they called it rabbit starvation which
is eating only rabbits which they felt
were so lean that they would starve to
death
wow anyway so i think that you know
eating
um if you're eating meat um
i i think it would be you know hard to
overeat saturated fats just because
you know the food itself has you know
the different fats in in some kind of
proportion so you're getting a certain
balance that's inherent
to this ancient food that humans have
been eating for
um of course for um millennia so
okay um can you can you you already
mentioned this earlier but just so i
have it
can you just name off these oils that
do end up causing inflammation so
safflower sunflower even canola
although canola is a little bit better
because they mix it with oleic
um there's yeah i think that avocado oil
is a little bit better
as a better profile with more ole
anything that's higher in oleic is going
to be better for you
olive oil of course i think is the um
pretty much the best one that you can
have but i would not use any of those
oils
for heating oh no not olive oil either
you know i in general i mean i do
sometimes but i think it's better um to
cook
with and apply heat to saturated fats
because there just is there's no chance
for
which coconut oil is good because that's
largely saturated
um and if you can stand the word you
know and butter or
ghee or duck fat is also highly
saturated uh i'm sure
people might might take offense at this
but lard
is a really good fat to cook with and
there are now people who are rendering
lard
or tallow or suet which is also which is
the fat from around the glands
of or the organ meat uh the organs of
the animal
okay so so in general i think that oils
are fine for cold applications but i
wouldn't be heating with them
and i would be very careful about the
restaurants you go to
not the restaurants so much just trying
not to order fried food in restaurants
because that will definitely have been
fried in
in prop most likely soybean oil soybean
oils is
the vast majority of oil you used in the
united states
um sorry i don't know for canada but
it's soybean oil and and
it's just the cheapest that is why yeah
is it subsidized uh
it may be it may well be most of our
grain crops are
yeah i think that soybean fields in
maybe i'm wrong someone will point it
out but i'm pretty sure they're
subsidized in canada
there is soybean oil is very popular so
is sunflower oil
right uh well i i think that
um and canola like canola oil is really
popular in alberta that's covered in
canola fields
right well you know canola was a product
of canada wasn't it the
the canadian it was a canadian product
that they invented
in general i just think that oils should
be used
for cold applications only and not be
heated
um i mean this
this story of how i came to learn that
that that
these polyunsaturated oils were so
dangerous came to me from
an executive in one of the major um
the major oil companies and he said to
me
do you have any idea what's happening
you know when trans fats went out of the
food supply
they've gone do you understand what
trans fats are maybe
like briefly describe what a trans fat
is okay well because
oils are unstable they have to harden
them
to make them um to make them
be like a saturated fat right so they
have to straighten out their molecules
and harden them to make things like
crisco
um and and and so or veg any kind of
hardened vegetable fat margarine that
process of hardening is called
hydrogenation and one of the byproducts
of that process
is trans fats and trans fats were
discovered to
very likely increase the risk of heart
disease so there was a big effort
starting in the early 2000s to get rid
of trans fats
which is all well and fine but nobody
thought about well what would replace
trans fats
and it turns out they just went back to
using regular old
unstable vegetable oils so
you know trans hydrogenation had served
served this process
it had served the function of
stabilizing oil
now we're back to unstable oils and
this is what i learned from this oil
executive who said oh and it's just
this was back in maybe 2013 or so he
said
this it's just terrible what's going on
he said we we don't know what to do
because now we have our vegetable oil
fryers at places like mcdonald's and
burger king and all these fast food
chains where the oils
are turning into like pollen like paint
polymers where they become all grand
sticky
right we have rancid but also like
hardening into
like you know those dried paint
and there was on the walls and and and
clogging up the drains of the fryers
and getting into people's hair and they
were so
they were such unstable molecules that
when the workers would take off their
uniforms for the day
and put them in the truck to go to the
dry cleaner the uniforms would
spontaneously combust
in the back of the truck because they
were such highly unstable molecules
now just think about those molecules you
know
circulating in the air of the restaurant
or getting into your
you know into your food which they do um
they get absorbed in the food and then
you're eating it
i mean i think it's there's a really
interesting scientist doing some work
about the effects of
of some of these um these kind of
degraded
what these are called linoleic linolenic
acids and and
you know he believes that a not large
amount of them
when consumed can send the body into
septic shock
um so i mean and it's ironically it's
the big major
fast food chains that have taken
measures to try to
to deal with this because of their
liability issues but also they don't
want their workers um
you know combusting and they they don't
want their drains clogging and their
walls being covered with gunk
so they have developed solutions like
putting nitrogen blankets
on top of the fryers or putting little
silicone beads
inside the oil to absorb the degrading
triglycerides but it's what's
you know the places to be more worried
about are actually your little mom and
pop
restaurants um where everything is fried
uh
you know like you know chinese food or
or
you know someplace where everything is
done in in fried oils
so this is what i think is worth being
concerned about um you know once places
got rid of trans fats
they did not replace them with healthier
fats
and it was just a pollen nobody really
looked into the future to see what would
happen
and they were they were stuck with these
um far less
healthy fats and they could of course
use a healthier fat like a canola oil or
um or olive oil but those are more
expensive so they just go with
um the cheapest version most places use
you know the cheapest option which is
soybean oil
yeah i went to um i was in serbia in the
summer
and i was trying to vary my diet just to
test out if i've you know
become less sensitive um and so i was i
tried
cooked fruit and i i went into like
chicken and duck and things because i
literally only ate beef and then lamb
for a while
um and i started not feeling so good and
so i went back
but it turns out i contacted this
restaurant i was going to which told me
they were making duck con
feet which was wonderful um
and i was not feeling good and not
feeling good and it turns out
when you cook calm feet you're supposed
to just cook it and it's so
fatty that it cooks and it it broils in
its own fat
but they were deep frying their duck
confit in sunflower oil
and i was eating that and i was not
feeling good
um and so my entire experiment was
ruined because i was occasionally eating
this
sunflower but i think most people don't
know like
they figured that was a perfectly
healthy dish right they were just
speeding up the process
about how they cooked it so they could
cook it faster if you just deep fry it
but
most people think that some sort of
vegetable oil is like
lighter and thinner and just better for
you
well that's what we've been told and
that is the official government
guidelines
in all nations is to replace saturated
with
all the unsaturated fats so it's no
surprise that we should think this way
we're just responding to what we are
we've been taught
um but remember those oil those oil
companies are
some of the biggest companies in the
world you're talking about unilever adm
monsanto
bungie um lotus crocolin i mean these
are
huge huge companies and they're very
sophisticated i mean when i
started looking into them i was just
dazzled by
how many scientists they fund and how
how involved they are
um even with our government agencies you
know the usda which
our our government agency that produces
our government guidelines is in
partnerships with unilever i mean it's
there are various levels of concern to
have about you know the the forces
behind this and then
and then you know all the experts
telling you um
this is the right you know what's the
correct way to eat is to eat these oils
so you know i only know one researcher
in the entire country
who is researching these oils and that's
no surprise there's that's no
coincidence and there's just not
research funding for
a subject that would overturn so much of
our
conventional thinking yeah and business
yeah
uh okay so what does if it's not
cholesterol that we should be concerned
about
um what what is it why has there been
such a rise in heart disease
do you like have you done any research
in the background of that
um yeah this so heart disease really
rose from
almost zero um and it really started
rising quickly in the 1920s it may have
been this is the u.s i'm talking about
i'm not sure if
i'm sure canada follows a symbol we
follow slowly behind whatever trends you
guys decide to have
i'm so glad we can export the best that
we have to you
i i think the answer is we don't truly
know but there are a number of strong
candidates
one of them is the increase in sugar and
refined carbohydrates
that are inflammatory and
means they cause inflammation in the
body and inflammation is what
one of one of the factors that drives
heart disease i think you know the other
astronomical rise um in consumption what
were vegetable oils
and there's um i think there's some
science now to show
you well that they're obviously
inflammatory and so
um so i think both of those are fair
contenders
in the diet world for what causes heart
disease but i
i don't think that we really know the
answer i know that it might be a number
of factors
right yeah i mean so what's interesting
is that
if you look at the you know there are
now some 100 experiments on low
carbohydrate diets
and they um and they show that when
people go on low carbohydrate diets they
they dramatically improve almost
every risk factor for heart disease
except for ldl
remember ldl is that stickler that
because of the
saturated fat it will increase a little
bit
but everything else across this spectrum
including inflammatory markers
all are reduced when you
reduce carbohydrates in the diet
so you would think that it's probably
carbohydrates that is then
if you were to flip that around which is
driving heart disease however
it's also true that most low
carbohydrate diets
are because of the way that um
the field has evolved they encourage you
to eat natural foods they do not they do
not encourage you to
eat a lot of processed foods that would
have vegetable oils in them in other
words when people reduce their
carbohydrates they're also reducing
their seed oils their vegetable oils and
so these things are happening
concurrently and so it's hard
to separate them out yeah
so it could be either or it could be the
combination of them
okay and that's the thing that i've
heard from my grandparents and all over
that
eating fat makes you fat like one one of
the i think the biggest reaction i get
to
telling people especially if i go into a
butcher shop or something telling people
that i've been eat
i don't even bring that up actually my
husband is like she only eats meat
like thanks i didn't want to have this
conversation but um
it's like shock that i'm not fat
um and then so there's still this
thought that like eating
meat but i think it's mainly eating meat
fat
makes you fat so do you think that the
things that make
people more inclined to gain weight
would that fall under the carb category
as well
or is that seed oils or a mix of things
my belief is that carbohydrates are
probably the major driver of obesity but
there could be
a role of seed oils as well um and
you know the idea that fat makes you
fat is one that
was floating around um in this 1970s
um well and earlier but but the idea was
basically like
fat has nine grams nine calories per
gram
versus protein or carbohydrate which
there's only three macronutrients fat
protein and carbohydrates so
fat has about twice as many calories per
gram
as as um as protein and carbohydrates so
it's just that why don't we just reduce
people's calories by reducing fat it was
a really simplistic idea and it had not
been tested but again it was the
american heart association
it was the american heart association in
1970 that started telling people
reduce your your total fat not just your
saturated fat but
all fat overall and this was the
beginning of the low-fat diet
um and there was really what what we
later
you know later science discovered is
that fat and protein
together are naturally satiating so you
and that you need fat um for your body
to function properly
so that people who ate diets with a
little more fat and protein were
um were and reducing carbohydrates
were more likely to become satiated
maybe eat less
um and and and the reduction in
carbohydrates you know carbohydrates is
really what
drives your this hormonal response in
your body
mainly insulin that is like the fat
storage hormone it just takes the
sugar in your bloodstream and it sticks
it into the fat cells
um so so reducing carbohydrates allows
you
to your body to um to not have as much
circulating sugar that then be stuck
into your fat cells by
this insulin hormone i had um i had ben
bickman on the podcast and we
went deep into insulin so okay so i
won't say anything more about it
yeah well if anyone wants to know more
about that
that's a good episode to check out okay
um last question
if i had to give an elevator pitch to
somebody on why
eating saturated fat wasn't going to
kill them like what's the short way of
explaining to people that this isn't
unhealthy
or or that it might even be healthy
saturated fats have been tested in more
nutritional studies than
any other in more than 60 000 people
they tested the question of whether
saturated fat causes heart disease and
the answer
was no they could not find evidence
it's been the most rigorously tested
hypothesis
in the history of nutrition and they
could not find the evidence that
saturated fats
cause heart disease so i think that
that's a pretty good pitch there's no
evidence there's just no evidence it was
a popular hypothesis
that became accepted before the evidence
was in
and then when they finally tested it
they could not find it to be true
and the dilemma that we face right now
is trying to back out of a hypothesis
that is not supported by the evidence
because now you know scientists since my
book came out and
and and there's been more and more
recognition more awareness that we might
have gotten it wrong on saturated fats
now there's 20 review papers
of or almost 20 review papers of all
those early clinical trials
oh great so and and then there are
reviews of review papers like what they
call them
umbrella reviews that review all those
papers and they all conclude
we probably got it wrong and saturated
fats the evidence really just is not
there
and then if you're saying well what
about site mode isn't it just better to
stay away from them how can they be good
for you you can say well it's the only
known food that raises your hdl
which is your good cholesterol going up
and i think
crucially saturated fat is an is part of
many
foods that are highly nutritious and
important you don't want to be avoiding
those foods on the basis of saturated
fats
you know we've been avoiding eggs and
butter and meat and cheese and these
foods are
highly dense in the nutrients needed
for life for
avoidance of disease and healthy living
as you well know
so you don't want to be avoiding those
foods and we've been avoiding those
foods in the basis of saturated fats and
that has been
that has been an error in other words it
has been something
without any scientific evidence so you
don't want to avoid healthy foods
well that that definitely answers that
question i think we'll turn that into a
clip that was a good one
where where can people find you online
um i'm at uh ninataishals.com
i'm my group the nutrition coalition
which has been working on the dietary
dietary guidelines is at
nutritioncoalition.us
and on twitter i'm on big fat surprise
i'm also on facebook just under my name
and i know it's a political act to say
what platform you're on these days but
[Laughter]
the only place i'm really active is on
twitter
okay that sounds good thank you
thank you very much for coming on that
was interesting thank you very much and
i would recommend
checking out the book i'll link it below
okay um
if you have any if anyone listening has
concerns about saturated fat
or wants to learn more about the history
of why it was demonized it is
rather interesting great thank you so
much
thanks for having me
[Music]
you